pnv zustand ist ein problem und dann
lieben wir halt einfach unsere autos es
ist ja so 8 und 48 millionen sind in
deutschland zugelassen und die brauchen
halt platz viel platz deutsche städte
werden seit jahrzehnten rund um die
bedürfnisse von autofahrern und autos
geplant man könnte auch sagen alle
anderen stören im grunde ein
selbstbedienungs ampeln belieben ist
gewisse fußgänger den ganzen verkehr für
sich anzuhalten
statt zu warten bis sich eine gruppe
angesammelt hat ebenso die umsätze den
fahrer durch absichtliches langsam gehen
zu provozieren ich hab schon zeit sagt
er sich ja wissen viele gar nicht wenn
man in den sechzigern so ein überfahren
hat gab es eine prämie vom adac das war
damals
zum kleinen duft baum
verkehrsplaner haben hier in deutschland
immer argumentiert noch mehr autospuren
entlasten den verkehr noch mehr
parkplätze neben den parkdruck das ist
wie wir heute wissen leider quatsch all
das lockt vor allem noch mehr autos in
die städte anderswo ist man schon viel
weiter paris zum beispiel da hat die
bürgermeisterin jede menge parkplätze
gestrichen und die fläche stellen sich
vor den radlern geschenkt london und
stockholm vertreiben autos mit der
sogenannten city maut und barcelona
drehte völlig durch der verkehr bleibt
fast ganz draußen beziehungsweise rund
herum es entsteht ein quadratisch buntes
städtisches idee also passt die mitten
in der stadt ohne todesangst kaffee
trinken das kann doch keiner wollen
meine damen und herren was sind denn das
für zustände oder in brüssel in brüssel
seit der tempo 30 eingeführt wurde ist
die zahl der unfalltoten um über 40
prozent zurückgegangen alles schön aber
bei uns leider so nicht denkbar dafür
sorgen autolobby und solche schlagzeilen
grüne machen ernst monster angriff auf
unser auto dabei wenn überhaupt kein
verkehrsmittel so massiv subventioniert
wie der pkw und trotzdem fühlt sich der
deutsche autofahrer grundsätzlich als
märtyrer in einer wunderbaren
autobahnkirche an der a5 gibt es sehr
schöne bleiglasfenster zu dem thema
direkt neben dem martyrium des heiligen
bartholomäus sieht man den leidensweg
des st tiguan der bittere tränen weint
weil der liter super plus 1 99 kostet
und der grüne dämon berbalk lacht dazu
ja die grünen übrigens laut tu dortmund
müssen sich insgesamt fünf prozent der
deutschen für ihr auto finanziell
einschränken um damit zur arbeit zu
kommen denen sollte die ampel gezielt
helfen stand immer mit der gießkanne
subventionen zu verteilen zum beispiel
eine leute die sich das e auto als
drittwagen kaufen oder noch schlimmer
die sich ein suv kaufen
zuschlag gewinnen ist es egal egal suv
anhaltend beliebt der direkte nachfahre
des panzers mit dem unsere großväter 1
durch europa cruz ja super beliebt immer
wieder platz 1 der deutschen
neuzulassung starts klima hin oder her
aber warum sind er sowieso populären so
psychologen sagen die rollende festung
gibt uns ein gefühl der sicherheit und
der entkopplung von der umwelt ja es ist
total angenehm du liegst einfach immer
ruhig und sicher auf der straße wenn man
jetzt mal als beispiel über ein
mittelgroßen hund drüber möllers
wirklich nur ein kaum wahrnehmbares
rücken und praktischerweise hört man
auch gar nicht was der wütende
hundebesitzer haben erzählen will oder
der typ der sauer ist weil man auf dem
radweg steht und wenn die erderwärmung
doch noch auf drei bis vier grad geht
kein problem dafür hat man ja die
klimaanlage meine damen und herren der
deutsche und sein suv eine unsterbliche
liebe und ich freue mich sehr ihnen
verkünden zu dürfen der kollege
friedemann weise hat genau dazu jetzt
die passende umweltbewegung gegründet
ich habe genau für diese bewegung eine
hymne auch geschrieben und diese hymne
heißt komm wir gehen an die ampel und
lachen suv fahrer auskommen wir gehen an
die ampel und lachende suv fahrer aus
[Musik]
autos abzufackeln
das hat keinen stil
und dann ihn zu wackeln bringt ja auch
nicht viel
komm wir gehen an die ampel und lachen
suv fahrer aus ja wir gehen eine jacke
und lachen hält vw fahrer aus jetzt alle
komm wir gehen an die jacke und ahmet
die fahrer aus ja wir gehen an die jacke
und lacht stopp stopp stopp ich wollte
nur zeigen wie leicht es ist so eine
populistische bewegung fort also
bemerkte stoppte 23 sekunden uns
überhaupt alle auf meiner seite aber
schön dass die mitgesungen haben das gut
aber das geht nicht wir können nicht
einfach pauschal alle suv fahrer an
pranger stellen dass so eine unart
unserer zeit oder immer direkt fackeln
und mistgabeln ohne die hintergründe zu
kennen wir wissen gar nicht wer da in
dem es so wie sitzt und warum vielleicht
sitzt ein mann drin der
hat überhaupt kein anderes auto
kann auch sagen vielleicht vielleicht
braucht das ja auch beruflich vielleicht
ist der zahnarzt oder makler kann auch
seine vermerke bestimmt mal so ein haus
im neubaugebiet ist noch nicht mal die
einfahrt gezehrt na ja da ist ja auch
jetzt gerade im winter der player mal
jetzt nicht schnee aber
vielleicht ist das auch ein älterer herr
der aus gesundheitlichen gründen suv
fährt habe ich im internet gelernt
wirklich sehr viele suv käufer sind
keine umwelt schweine sondern ältere
herrschaften die aus dem kleinwagen
nicht mehr richtig aussteigen können da
tut die kiste wsj ist sind die einzigen
auto würde mit wo du mit über 60 noch
halbwegs würdevoll aussteigen kannst
seitdem ich das weiß wundere ich mich
nicht mehr wenn ich alte menschen im suv
sehe was mich wundert ist warum gibt es
die dinge überhaupt im autohaus und
nicht im sanitäts fachgeschäft
wichtig ist es auch suv fahren zuzuhören
wenn ich jetzt ein großeinkauf hab oder
was weiß ich was ich einmal ein solches
das alles auch mein rücken es ist immer
sache da hilft so su wie sehr viel
kaufen so ist meine keine ahnung die
autos gibt schon seit tausenden von
jahren
er hat doch recht die zu tausenden von
jahren wir sind auch hier der der stein
vor jesus grab ich sag mal so den haben
die bestimmt nicht mein pferd 500
weggezogen also wir haben gelernt
pauschale vorverurteilungen sind immer
falsch und deshalb sehen wir das lied
vom anfang jetzt nochmal aber diesmal
mit moralisch korrekten text und zwar
kommen wir gehen an die ampel und
schubsen liege radfahrer um direkt
zusammen ja wir gehen an die ampel und
schützen die
geraten
[Musik]
[Applaus]
na ja genau ja ja die zuschauer
mittlerweile fast alle versteckten
symbole bei uns im neuen studio gefunden
wie laminat die freimaurer staatsführung
ist alles dabei dann wollen wir denn die
eigentlichen strippenzieher bekanntgeben
erst bei so vielen abonnenten auf
youtube
also ich würde mich ran halten